also in other news a multi-vehicle crash
leaves a woman dead and a teen in jail
it happened yesterday afternoon at
washington and torrey pines and it was
such a dynamic scene involving six
vehicles that investigators were there
until about 11 o'clock last night that's
where victoria saha joins us with why
that teen was arrested
marks are still visible on the ground
from the police investigation as they
tried to piece together this deadly
crash investigators say 18 year old
jerry medeiro is speeding in his 2007
toyota rav4 westbound on washington he
ran through the red light to torrey
pines hitting and killing 34-year-old
georgina madrigo oliveiras of las vegas
as she was making a turn madeira's car
crashed into three other cars and caught
on fire he did suffer serious injuries
and another driver suffered minor
injuries three others were not hurt
mario navero lives nearby and heard the
crash he and his neighbors are concerned
with the constant speeding in the area
we heard a loud bang
and
kind of like living here for a couple
years i already knew kind of what it was
one of my neighbors actually he came out
and
with a fire extinguisher because
before the fire department got here it
was
already on fire navarro says he
witnessed many crashes here and this was
by far the worst madera faces charges of
reckless driving and dui he was expected
in court wednesday afternoon but was
still being treated at a hospital the
judge says at this time there will not
be a bail from madeira he returns to
court on monday reporting near torrey
pines and washington victoria saha live
local now